hey welcome to the monitor hey it's a
celebration got a big week this week
that's why I'm standing up we're going
to talk about the return of a great old
video game to a new screen we're going
to talk about a new comic from the best
creator-owned line in the business but
first we're going to turn the monitor
into the hobbit or not because the movie
is out this week because it is not it is
out next week and we will talk about it
then but because it is the hobbit week
on the colbert report on comedy central
not only are their guests from the
hobbit all week on the show from martin
freeman to Peter Jackson to ian mckellen
but there is a graph if they're running
at the beginning the show that really
needs to be seen to be appreciated if
not outright believed why wouldn't you
believe it of course they do it it's a
TV show they have that kind of money but
it's fantastic and it's also pretty
funny it's kind of like those New Yorker
covers with the fake maps I love a fake
map I love a fake map but they do a good
fake map it's a good fake middle-earth
maps like New York of middle-earth to
see what I'm getting that any way to
good we could television I always like
when they do a theme thing or they go a
place where they do a thing and they're
doing a thing on The Colbert Report it's
after the daily show all week long on
Comedy Central let's talk about comic
books now image comics which of course
is a great creator-owned line has been
having a pretty incredible 2012 I've
talked about the book fatale on the show
I have talked about the book saga on
this show there have been others that I
will talk about in our year-end show but
the newest in the great image project
starts this week it is called blackacre
it is written by Duffy Boudreaux a name
which in my mind goes with kind of an
outsize Cajun chef and it is drawn by
wendell cavalcanti first issue also as a
cover by michael avon aiming who's a
favorite artist of mine basically it
takes place in the near future in a time
when piracy on the high seas is tipped
the geopolitical balance concurrently
there is a shadowy force in the United
States that has claimed federal lands
ostensibly for good but has instead
erected this gleaming high-rise city
state called blackacre it is crazytown
it is a tale of class warfare and
espionage and deception and uncertainty
there have nothing
there have alots there is a guy named ho
who was a paramilitary guard on the wall
which might sound a lot like Game of
Thrones I know it did to me but there's
a very similar concept in in the book
blackacre at any rate while Boudreau and
Cavalcanti are both relative newcomers
the book has garnered a lot of
pre-release buzz writers like Jonathan
Hickman and Matt Fraction have already
thrown the weight of their cosines
behind it and I would like to add my own
totally insignificant voice to that mix
I think it's a great debut i think it's
an auspicious first issue and if you're
looking for something new i highly
recommend it it's at shops now it's
online now it's called blackacre to out
on image let's talk video games so we
have talked about Middle Earth and we
have talked about future espionage it's
clearly time for gangsters and hookers
because rockstar games for the 10th
anniversary of grand theft auto vice
city is bringing it out this week for
iOS devices and I'm not saying you
should play it on your phone though you
probably could I'm saying you're going
to want to play it for your larger
device your iPad your iPad Mini your
iPad Maxie I don't know if you have a
maxi pad try it on that at any rate it
is essentially the exact same game as
the original vice city which of course
follows tommy vercetti through a very la
ish a simulacrum we might we say of la
wheeling and dealing and shooting and
killing and pillaging if your super-ego
is getting tired from controlling your
it'd and you want to let your it out
play a GTA game there is nothing unless
you wreak havoc like that nothing that
encourages wreaking havoc like that if
you have a moral compass put it back in
your pocket then download gta vice city
and play it and celebrate its 10th
anniversary in style that is it for this
week on the monitor we will be back next
week I don't know why I'm pointing with
alternating hands let's do Jazzercise
but you can always email us but until we
see you next week inspirational
catchphrase here
you